just over seven months ago Sky News
broke the news that Sir Martin Sorrell
had left the world's biggest advertising
and marketing services agency after 32
years at the helm headlines over the
reasons for that departure reports of
misconduct under our for his
remuneration followed but just weeks
later he started all over again
founding rival group s for capital it's
just made its second major acquisition
buying San Francisco based advertising
technology firm mighty hive for one
hundred and fifty million dollars Sir
Martin Sorrell joins me now mr singh
great to see you so what is my t hive
might have is a programmatic media
planning and buying business which means
it buys advertising on the on the web
digitally through algorithms it's highly
targeted advertising use the content
that we have in within s for capital so
buy produced by media monks which is a
digital content firm and then deploys
that distributes it through media
planning and buying technologically
based media planning and buying through
the world so what are you trying to
achieve with s for capital well I looked
when I when I left I was ejected or
electrocuted how have you put it at a
WPP I looked at the growth areas of WPP
and I think there were three one was
digital content so media monks was our
first deal and we bought ten country
twelve office operations just open in
San francisco-based originally in
Holland but focusing on digital content
of all kinds but particularly in
advertising that was one area second
area was media planning and buying a
mighty high visa just said it represents
that so bringing the two together
fuelled by what we call first party data
which means client data or platform data
so the sort of data that Google has or
Facebook has or Amazon or ten cent or
Alibaba that we can use to educate the
content that we develop and educate the
media planning and buying we do so that
we're highly targeted we understand how
consumers are purchasing goods and
services and in a more modern way and
and their tastes and preferences in a
more sophisticated technologically based
way so what are the gaps in the
portfolio what do you think that the
train set is is almost complete I think
is probably three-quarters 7/8 of the
way there probably I'd like to do a
little bit more in the content area
media monks is very strong
but it's still small and I describe it
as a peanut or maybe some morphing to a
coconut but we're certainly we're not a
big company we're more a motor torpedo
boat than an aircraft carrier and and I
think what we have to do is perhaps
enliven even more our content part of
our business and maybe a little bit in
the first party data area but we really
have got to two companies which are very
very strong in content and media
planning and buying and I think the acid
test for us is now going to be how we
can broaden deepen a very good client
lease you have an excellent client list
based in packaged goods based in
technology and financial services in
hospitality in a number of areas but
what we have to debt they're not big
relationships they have to be broadened
and deepened so what I'm looking for now
is we have the access I think for our
two companies and working together in a
sophisticated way what we have to do is
to deliver once we have the access and
convert what about those clients I mean
this is a period of immense disruption
we've seen industry opportunities well
we've seen banking disruptive we see on
media disrupted a lot of these
traditional becomes our own industry at
it but FMCG the lights of Unilever yes
from gamble they are facing immense
disruption are they going to have the
money to pay advertise well men like you
thought it was they did 40 percent of
their budgets are going on digital so
the world is I mean the advertising
marketing service is about a trillion
dollars about 500 billion the old stuff
500 billion in the different stuff as
the 500 billion in the traditional area
of that now 200 billion is in digital
that's enough to go around it is in fact
in terms of absolute cost a cheaper area
to penetrate it is more targeted it is
more accurate it is more sophisticated
there there are more measurement metrics
than you have you know the old saying I
know a waste half my advertising but I
then wish off I think probably in
digital is you you know you waste 25
percent or 15 percent but you don't know
which 15 or 25 percent so it's much
easier to identify the cost now our
mantra interest me to your point is
faster better cheaper in a world since
layman since 19 since Oh 8 since 2008
in a world where there's very little
inflation where nominal GDP growth as a
result is less than it was pre layman
where there's very little pricing power
the the onus on the clients is to to
focus on costs and that's what we have
to respond to so the mantra of faster
being faster in an always on 24/7
digital world
you're almost running political
campaigns I mean that they go on for
longer than political campaigns but it's
almost the same and the the velocity and
the the vibrancy of the other campaigns
is very strong so faster it's very
important better means utilizing new
technology in more sophisticated ways
and using all fronts a IVR virtual
reality augmented reality and very
sophisticated voice in very
sophisticated ways and then probably the
most important is to be more efficient
because in most companies the finance
and procurement function has become much
more powerful I would say in the last
ten years that the balance has shifted
from marketing to finance and
procurement I don't think that's right
because top-line growth will always be
the determinant where you I mean that
condition the way I looked at this for
capital and I left WPP so what about
that departure from WPP Williams
reflections on it's seven months or I
would say I'm sad about it then in a way
I mean wpv is not today for example you
know we see another lurch downward in
the in the share price tonight you know
I worry about it obviously I'm still a
major shareholders you invited me but
supercell yeah yes I'm still a top-ten
shareholder I think probably the largest
individual shareholder so I care very
much about its future and future
development s4 Capital is a very
different model I I don't think it's
competitive really I mean you can't
compare 150 million dollar revenue
company with twenty billion dollars over
there operating in very different
different areas and different ways in
many respects I mean we do collide on
occasion in both the acquisitions
actually that we made medium accent
Maggio I think WPP was a knitter so I
guess it's to nil halfway through the
first half of its that personal for you
then you're really trying to put well no
it's not it's not personal I mean yeah I
was asked Gideon Spaniard camp
asked me you know is is there a revenge
motive there and I said well no but you
know if ever there was a revenge element
to it the challenge is to build coming
back to your questions the new age new
era model that will be successful I mean
what I really want to do and my
colleagues want to do Media monks and
mighty hive is put together a probably a
revolutionary rather than evolutionary
but a revolutionary disruptive model
that appeals to clients in terms of the
content that we create for them in that
24/7 always-on world and the way that we
deliver it in terms of programmatic or
media planning and buying that's a
really listen man I think back on my
last sort of a year or so at wpv there
were three or four things that I saw
where there were true differentiation
that what we did clearly marked out a
difference so what we're trying to do
here is is to create a new model which
is very different for us come come
before very much attune to the
disruption that you talked about which
affects all industries but there were
some very yurid headlines surrounding
your departure I mean that both of
wounded you it didn't move me I mean the
fact of the matter when you read
articles they refer to those those
allegations or images of the way that
newspapers get round any legal problems
they fail to point out that there was an
investigation and what that
investigation found found me is a good
lever and found nothing material so they
sort of the report half the story and
they don't report the other half which
is again investigation good lever
departure I denied going legal action
there's no against me now yeah I mean
one of the interesting I mean you're
you're 73 years old yes you've amassed
more money than you can spend in this
world all the next what's made you go
and do it all again I've had three lives
not not nine lies another six to go that
three lies one with the Sarge's one with
WPP and now with one with this for
capital I mean I can't see myself
retiring to the beach or on the golf
course I think Golf is for all men I've
probably offended a lot of people out
there so sorry and I can't see most of
doing a portfolio series things but I
really want to remain at
I think when you retire you know and you
you are inactive that has I think mental
and physical effects on people that
water from what I've seen so I think
keeping active is really important and I
enjoy this you know we've had it hasn't
been an easy six months but we've now I
set myself a target of doing three
things actually by Christmas and we've
done two so I'm very pleased with the
progress we've made you try things
differently a DES for capital than you
did it yes it's a unitary structure so
so the board we have now four
non-executive directors so we have a
four that we add through the funding
then Daniel Pinto from Stanhope the
executive directors of media monks
Victor nappa Mosley Taha will join from
Media monks and Peter Kim peat Kim and
Christopher Martin will join from mighty
have so I have those for myself as
executive chairman plus the
non-executive it will be a unitary board
I think there is a real issue and this
is somewhat controversial things to say
but here goes I mean rather like fund
management where you have the split
between performance and governance in
companies I think you're getting the
split between so the chairman and
general counsel there's a sort of
process line and then there's a
performance line with the CEO and the
management and and never to will meet
and and I think you know the the split
structure is probably a better structure
than the concentrated structure in
America where you have chairman and CEO
is one person with the scenery
independent director but the danger is
you know if the chairman or chairwoman
is not comfortable in his or her t-shirt
or not comfortable in in themselves and
don't feel that they've got the t-shirt
there are some tensions that can creep
in there and and you know you have sort
of split leadership and split
responsibilities and sometimes I think
that can be unhealthy that I mean the
best chairman Phil later was a great
chairman of WPP Hamish Maxwell you know
who ran what was I think for one quarter
the biggest company in the world Philip
Morris a bigger than Citibank at that
time but you know he'd been there done
it didn't was not trying to to
grandstand in any way as chairman and
was very sage advisor and unconfident
but will you be personally different
though as a leader have you following
what happened WPP here's where we're all
we're all conditioned by our experiences
you know good bad or indifferent the
true test of anybody I think is is
really not how you deal with the good
things you deal with the good things all
the good times is easy it's how you deal
with the tough times the answer I think
is absolutely critical and you know how
you rebound from from adversity or or
challenges or you know the way that
we've made the right or wrong decisions
now that you're of a renowned reader of
the economic rooms what do you make of a
brexit debate and what it's doing to the
UK economy well I I think for some time
people are being on hold their very
least I mean I think some people have
been postponing and we're discussing
before we came on air that people are
responding making decisions and I think
that's been bad for the economy for a
long period of time ironically in the
advertising business and one of the
puzzling things was in over the last
year or say the UK has actually been
quite a strong market and why is that
well I think it's because people have
been refraining from capital investment
fixed plant investment increasing
capacity and what they'd be more likely
to do to his invest in brands sort of
tickle up sales or hold market share or
increase market share through increased
ad spending and marketing spending to
try and stimulate sales so I think this
sort of had a slightly paradoxical
effect because usually in times of
uncertainty people cut back but I just
can't see anybody making a major
investment decision with the degree of
uncertainty that we see going on and you
know we were talking before also about
what's going on in France with micron
ratings and the and the challenges to
his leadership there what we see in
Germany with a change of leadership what
we see in Italy with the the coalition
there you know a left and right wing
populist regime at least temporarily I
think and then what we see in Spain so
ironically you know if I was a brexit II
which I'm not on there very much remain
and I would like there to be a second
referendum although I doubt whether that
will happen but if I was a brick sit
here I'd be looking at your own saying
to myself oh my gosh they are in a bit
of a pickle quite how many but but what
about Theresa Mays deal I mean do you
think it's a decent compromise for
British business well I don't know the
the intricacies of the negotiation it's
not what I would like to have seen and I
think the backstop issue is an issue I
mean I find it a little bit
that we're being told to take this deal
because there's nothing else on offer I
mean it's not the right way I think we
should take the very best deal that we
can possibly negotiate not the only one
that we were able to negotiate in my
view but my guess is for what it's worth
we we did a fund raising as you know
around the city last week and I think
the general consensus was that whilst
the the first vote might go against the
prime minister ultimately the second
vote might go with her maybe with a few
modifications interesting stuff all
right sue Martin so we've got to leave
it there great to see you too thank you